Happy Monday everyone! How you all doing? You
know it's good because it's a goodie bag day
and so I'll get to what you have in your hands in
this lecture. Today-- So we've been talking about
these things for a while now, right? We've built
up an understanding of the stamp and the basis,
and then we understood how to talk about it
like in terms of the planes and the symmetries,
and then we shined x-rays on it, and now we're
going to start taking them all apart. And so don't
be sad, don't be sad, because actually that's more
real-- that's more real. And that's what we'll
talk about today. So what our plan is-- you know--
So today we're going to start creating defects
in the perfect order that we've had so far. And
in your goody bag you have a defect generation
machine, which we'll talk about. And then on--
And so today we're gonna talk about one kind
of defect, that's a point defect, and then
on Wednesday we'll talk about line defects,
and then we'll just mess the whole thing up,
and we're going to make it amorphous. So that's
where we're going. And beyond that if you
want to know more about where we're going,
there's the concept map up there for exam 3.
Which again, you know we don't pick these dates,
so this date came later in the semester that
we wanted but it's that's what it is. I think
it's all the way up in early December. But--
Because of the fact that there's a Thanksgiving
holiday in between and there's one topic here
we have to start before the exam. It's not here
because it won't be on the exam but we're going to
start polymers but won't be on the exam. I'm going
to spend the whole lecture before exam three just
reviewing for exam three, because we're gonna have
that Thanksgiving break and all that. So that's
what's not listed here these are just the topics
that are covered on exam three. Okay. Good. If
anyone has any questions please do let me know.
The concept map. Now the thesis of 3.091
you have seen in multiple different ways.
I have tried to convey to you that
the electronic structure of atoms
is the key to life. It's the key to chemistry.
It's the key to understanding and within that
you get things like this which is what we've
been talking about recently like composition
and arrangement. Right? That's these crystals
that's these different-- BCC FCC. Okay.
And then the chemistry you put inside. But
you see the other thing about it is defects.
Because the thing is that defects, which is the
topic of today and Wednesday, they are absolutely
crucial for understanding the properties.
If they're there and I just told you they're
always there. The question is how much are they
there? And so if you don't know about defects--
if you don't know about defects then you
really cannot fully understand properties.
There is a very strong correlation between the
two and that's why we have to talk about them.
We have to understand them. Now I love
this quote from Colin Humphreys he said,
"Crystals are like people, it is the defects
in them which tend to make them interesting."
Yeah. And that's actually really true because
defects, right, defects sound you know... 'I
don't want to defect.' No, actually oftentimes
you do want defects. Sometimes you don't. So
there are some kinds that are kind of like
maybe not things you want in your crystal
and then there are other kinds that actually you
are engineering purposefully to be there. Either
way you got to understand them. Right? And that's
what we're doing today because --Gesundheit-- so
you know if you take this three layer-- We talk
about graphene. It's a one atom thick material.
Pretty cool-- every atom's on the surface. Here's
another example of what's called a 2D material.
Why? It's not 2D but it's called a 2D material
because it gets you like... you know more
publicity on your work. This is molybdenum--
this is molybdenum disulfide it's really cool
material. It's three atoms thick. So it's kind of
like 2D-ish, right? Yeah but see that's the model.
That's the model. This is reality. This is real--
How do you see-- How do we see atoms like this?
That's a real picture. Do we use x-rays?
No? What do we use to see atoms that well?
Electrons. Electrons are our light, right? That's
what we're using. This is an electron picture,
electron. And if you do that you can
see individual atoms and look at that
there's there's places where atoms are missing all
over the place. That's reality. That's reality.
And those where you have one atom missing or
where you have one thing that is localized and
disruptive to the regularity of the lattice...
that's called a point defect. So let's write that
down. That's the one that we're talking about
today. So the point defect, 'point defect', is
where you have a localized...
localized disruption...
in the regularity, 'regularity'.
The periodicity the repeating of the lattice.
And it could be on or between,
we'll see this, on or between
sites. Right? It could be a defect that is, like
you see here, there's an actual atom missing. What
could be something that maybe you've got in there
in between sites? But either way it's a disruption
that's localized to a point or almost a point.
And so it is --Gesundheit-- that you can see that
if we just make these disruptions in something.
Alumina. We talk about alumina, right? Remember
alumina's really strong lattice energies? So
it's like sandpaper. Oh, it's also toothpaste.
It's in a lot of stuff. Alumina is a great--
But look at this. That's alumina with almost
no defects. It's still got some. You can never get
rid of them all! But here it is when I purposely
engineer the defects in alumina and I put a
little titanium or iron. Or here's it when
I put chromium. So you can-- There's one property
where the localized disruption, and it's not a lot
as we'll see, the localized disruption changes
the properties. That is key. That's just color.
Right? This applies to most properties of
materials. And so this first one, the point
defects that we're talking about today, you can
kind of think of those as zero dimensional because
they're they're localized. You know. They
don't really go off in a line. They don't
go off in a plane or a volume. And you can
have defects that are that cover all of those
possibilities. But these are points. Alright?
This is what the word localized means here, okay?
Okay. Now in this class, we're not going to cover
all of them, but we will cover these two. Today:
this one. On Wednesday: that one. And that'll
give you enough of a sense of the role of defects
and how to think about defects and crystals.
Right? So this is how we think and classify
defects. Okay. Now the four-- so now we're
going to point defects-- now the four,
there are different types of point defects that
can happen. The one that you saw here is a certain
one. That's called a vacancy. It's because there's
an atom that's vacant. So you literally just lost
an atom somewhere in there. Okay? Now that's a
vacancy and that always exists. But you could also
have taken something like one of the atoms that's
already in there, maybe an aluminum or an oxygen
that's in the lattice, and you could substitute
something in place of that. That's another-- Why
is that a point defect? Because I didn't like
tear something out. But no, but you changed the
regularity. Localized disruption and regularity.
So if I put something else in for aluminum
that's a point defect. Right? And again, now go
back to here. You can see it here. So we classify
these, right? There's a vacancy, which is an atom
missing. There's what's called an interstitial,
which is an atom that goes in between the other
atoms. Here it's a self interstitial so it's the
same type of atom. And these are-- This is where
you have a different type of atom in between and
this is where you have a different type of atom
as well. Those are both called impurities and I
will talk about those all today. We're gonna start
and focus a lot of our attention on the vacancy.
And that's what I want you to use this goodie bag
to understand, is the vacancies. Okay. Vacancies.
Why do vacancies happen? What are vacancies? To
understand vacancies in crystals we have to talk
about this guy. And oh... this guy was brilliant.
This-- I'm sure you know his name is Svante. Yeah,
it's written right there. Svante Arrhenius.
Arrhenius studied in the late 1800s so many
different things and made so many contributions
that it's almost hard to catalog. He was
brilliant. And you know he won the nobel prize
in chemistry for his work on electrolytes.
But he also worked on immunology. He was the very
first person in the late 1800s to come up with a
model for global warming and the role of CO2 in
the temperature change of the planet. And his
predictions were actually pretty darn good. He
was brilliant. And one of the things that he did
is, he observed what it were called activated
processes, and how they depended on temperature.
And so we have this equation that I need to
talk about today and it's going to come back.
So we're going to talk about this equation,
which is the Arrhenius equation, that relates
the rate of some process to the temperature. And
the activation energy for that process. So we got
to talk about what all that means, alright? Now
we will be using this. Today we're going to use
it to think about concentrations of vacancies in
a crystal which follow Arrhenius-like behavior.
Right? But then we're going to come back to it
when we go into reaction kinetics in a couple
of weeks. Where we talk about reaction rates. So
we'll be using Arrhenius multiple times throughout
the rest of the semester. So what is it? So the
Arrhenius-- So the general Arrhenius equation can
be written like this. Arrhenius, he was not in
the army but this is just the general equation.
Okay. So let's put equation there. And so we have
k, which is some rate, equals A. I'll talk about
each of these. Times e the exponential of e to
the minus Ea over RT. What are these things?
So this is the general equation for the rate of
some process. As we're going to see this applies
to many, many processes including vacancies.
Okay. But this is sort of the rate. So you can
think of this as-- Okay. Let's just-- That's the
rate of a process rate. The rate of some process.
Okay. I mean you could think about it as the
number of times something happens per second.
That's a rate. Right? It doesn't have to be those
units, but that's like a rate. Right? How often
does this happen. The rate-- But now so that's
dependent on something called the pre-exponential,
that I will talk about. 'Pre-exponential--
exponential'. That is a factor that is a constant.
And here we have this exponent-- and this
is such a beautiful expression. So this is
the average thermal energy. 'average kinetic
energy, average thermal energy' Right? It's
taking temperature and it's making an energy out
of it. Now remember we've already talked about
this before. That you know you don't get what you
get are distributions. So you know this would be T
high-- remember I've drawn this exact thing and
this might be T low and this might be-- You know,
this might be the you know the probability of
something happening. Probability of occurring.
And then in this case we talked about this
as the kinetic energy of the molecules.
That's a graph we showed already. But so the--
But this RT is an average. But so I just want
to make sure you don't forget. This is a number.
This is a number. You've got at 300 degrees, at a
thousand degrees, you calculate a number here.
But whenever you're talking about temperature,
you're talking about distributions. There's some
average of the distribution but you're always
talking about distributions. That's important for
understanding Arrhenius. Okay. Now this thing here
is called the activation energy. Activation
energy. And that is the energy that you have
to get over for something to happen. For
the thing to happen. Let's take-- I love
this analogy of the bookcase. I'm going to draw
that now. So let's suppose that you have energy,
like that. Okay. So maybe this is like potential
energy. Yeah, let's go ahead and say potential
energy. Then if I've got a bookcase and it's very
very heavy. And I try-- and I want to push it over
on this hinge. So I want to rotate it and push
over. Then you could imagine that at some point
it's going to look like this. And then
at another point, it's going to look
like this. Right? So this is like step one,
and that's step two, and that's step three.
And now I'm pushing this thing over. Well this is
the activated state. Why? Because it's where I've
gotten to the highest energy, and that's where
this energy graph is important. This energy axis,
this is the activated state of the bookcase.
Right? So if I plot the the energies.
Right? You can say one, two, three. You
can think about it like that. Right?
I've literally-- So because it's a potential
energy, right? So it's like here's the
gravitational pull, here it went up a little bit.
Right? So you can think about it just like that.
And here it came back down. That's why I like
this analogy because it really gives you intuitive
feeling for what's happening here. There's a
process. The process is pushing the bookcase over.
That bookcase has some energy associated
with it. Here and here. Potential energy.
And it's got some energy I gotta put into
it to activate it to go from here to here.
Right? That's why that's called the activation
energy. That's what this Ea means for the general
Arrhenius equation. You're pushing the bookcase
over. Yeah but how are you going to push it over?
Well clearly you're going to run
around the room and accidentally
knock into it because that's temperature.
Maybe that's not a good-- But if you had a
lot of people running around a bookcase maybe
once in a while they'd kind of bang into it.
Thermal energy. Right? And then maybe another
time, you increase how fast everyone's running,
and you give them more energy. So now not only
are they hitting it more frequently but they're
they're actually hitting it with more energy.
They're able to give it more energy. Now you make
everyone run really fast. And the chances that
this thing goes through that process are higher.
That's what that is. That's a probability,
right? This is what this exponential is. That
was the brilliance of what he did right.
So this thermal energy is like, you know,
it's how much-- It's like a probability but that's
why it goes into an exponential. Because when you
increase temperature, again it's not just that
you're increasing how much energy over here,
Right? How this is get like kinetic energy of
some molecules. Maybe how much energy those
molecules have but you're increasing how many of
them are above some threshold. So your chances
go exponentially higher. Well you think if
it was harder and harder to push. But this
is going to go the other way too. You could have
sometimes somebody might knock it the other way.
It looks kind of hard from this picture.
But there's a chance. It's just that
the activation energy going this way, right?
Going this way, the activation energy is here.
'Ea' and going this way the activation
energy would be here. So this would be 'Ea'
for, let's see, three to one. And this
would be 'Ea' for one to three. Now again,
I am giving you the general Arrhenius. We will
be coming back to this when we do reaction rates.
We will be coming back to this picture, and we
will be talking about reactions, and then we'll
be using that, and going to equilibrium. Today,
I want to give you a sense for what Arrhenius is
because this is where the equation comes from. And
because if you think about now defect formation.
Defect formation is an activated-- it's a
thermally activated process. But that's exactly
the point. So that's why if we write this down--
I've said this now multiple times the vacancy...
'vacany'. No. Vacancy is
always present. Always present!
Why? Because it's thermally activated. So unless
I can get to T equals zero-- thermally activated.
There's always a chance that I
push a vacancy into the material.
There's also always a chance
that the vacancy gets pushed out.
So those are happening because of temperature.
You can think about that. It kind of makes sense,
right? Atoms are moving. Those are the people--
right-- there's the people in the room.
And now all of a sudden, something happens
somewhere that allows an atom to come out.
We'll talk about that in a second. And create
a vacancy. Now there's a chance that it can go
back too, right? And so there's at some point
there's an equilibrium concentration. Both of
those are thermally activated processes that have
an Arrhenius like behavior. And so you get to...
the very nice expression for concentration.
So you can get-- can get? Yeah,
why not-- get concentration. So
the concentration at equilibrium.
Since vacancy formation is thermally activated
and it's thermally deactivated. There's some--
you know, you can say well when it's activated
and deactivated in the same rates you're in
equilibrium. That's how you get a concentration.
And I don't need you to know the math
but I need-- This is where it comes from. The
number of vacancies divided by the total number
of sites is equal to e to the minus E vacancy--
I will talk about this-- vacancy divided by,
let's use RT still. RT. Now here's the thing
about RT. Let's write this down because this
is really important, right? If-- we talked about
this before-- if I'm using RT then it's per mole.
Per mole use RT. This is the ideal
gas constant, right? That's not just
used for ideal gases. This is used for a
lot of things. That's the gas constant.
Gas constant. That's equal to-- let's see if i
have down here-- 8.314 joules per mole Kelvin.
So you see if I'm working in per mole, then I use
R. This is-- the energy unit the-- those energy
units have to be the same. They got to cancel. So
if my activation energy is in per mole, fine, use
the gas constant. If the activation energy is in
per atom then we just use the Boltzmann constant:
kBT. Where the Boltzmann constant
is something we have seen,
it is equal to the ideal gas constant divided by
Avogadro's number. Remember that Avogadro's number
goes in and out atomic macroscopic worlds
so R and kB same thing. Okay. One thing--
notice that's per Kelvin. Whenever you have
equations like this that come from thermodynamics,
which is where these things come from.
There is only one temperature unit. There
is no other. And it is Kelvin. You have to be
aware of that. If you see something in Celsius,
it's not going to work. It's got to be Kelvin.
All of these equations have to use Kelvin. Okay.
So that now-- you can see at any
time, you know, any time you see
an equation with an exponential.
What's the first thing you want to do?
I mean it's like an-- it's almost like an
instinctual reaction. You see an exponential. Take
a log. Don't say anything until you take a log.
Right? So that's an-- so that-- so we're talking
about energy of the vacancy in a minute. But if
you take a log of this. Then you get that the log
of what '|n(Nv)'. Well I'll talk
about that. Equals log of N.
Let's do it this way. Minus
log of n equals E vacancy.
Okay. Divided by RT. That's just taking an
exponential, a logarithm of this equation. And
now I can talk about these Nv and N. So Nv is--
this is literally a concentration. This is the
concentration of vacancies that are forming in my
crystal. Why did i get this expression and notice
the constant cancelled. This pre-exponential
factor cancelled. It canceled because
I'm taking a concentration. I'm looking at the
rate going one way and the rate going the other.
And I get to take a ratio of those. That leads
me to this expression. That's how you get from
Arrhenius rates to some concentration. Okay. But
you still-- but notice it's still-- we call this
Arrhenius-like because it's still an exponential
dependence. It's not a rate, it's a concentration.
It's okay. It's a concentration in equilibrium.
So this would be like the number of vacancies,
number of vacancies. And this one here
'n' would be like the number of sites,
number of lattice sites. So it's like you
know concentration. Lattice sites. Right?
And what is this? This is exactly here, here we
go. I have my crystal. Okay. Here's my crystal and
here it is... I think I'll
stop here. And now I did this.
We're going to go graphical and this and this.
That energy is literally the energy difference.
It's literally the energy difference between
having a vacancy and not having
a vacancy. How much energy--
Question? [STUDENT:] Isn't there supposed to
be a negative sign in front of the E vacancy?
[PROFESSOR:] Yes there is. Oh yes there
is. Yes there is. Thank you very much.
Yes. So that's-- Okay. So now the energy
difference between having a vacancy and not,
is the vacancy formation energy. E vacancy. Now
sometimes, and this is unfortunate, but sometimes
you will see the vacancy formation energy written
as the activation energy. That's fine. I mean it
just it's written that way to get across the
point that it's an Arrhenius-like behavior.
But actually the act-- but
if you're clear about it.
And that's why I want to go through the bookcase
example, right? The formation energy which is this
energy of the vacancy forming is the difference
between here and here. The activation energy
is this hill that you got to get over to go back
and forth. Okay? So the formation energy between
having a vacancy and not is what goes into our our
equation. Alright. Now we're going to use this.
So we will see how this works in just a few
minutes. But again there are so many processes
that are thermally activated. There are so many
processes that have Arrhenius-like behavior.
That are Arrhenius-like. And if you go to
Dartmouth then they'll give you goodie bags
with live crickets. And actually I really
hope not. But this is one of the labs that
they have where they take crickets and they
measure the number of times a cricket chirps.
And they're like, well okay. Let's measure the
cricket chirp over 13 seconds. We're gonna cool
them down, hopefully not too cold, and then we're
going to heat them up, hopefully not too hot.
Because crickets are nice, right? And so
then-- and they ca-- but look at that. And
they count it. And then what do they do? Well they
didn't know about Arrhenius yet until somebody
from MIT went and visited. So the first thing
they did is they plotted the data. Look at that.
Chirps per 13 seconds plotted. And they're all
sitting there trying to fit a straight line to
it. And then someone from this class is up
there visiting. They're like, you know what
i think, this looks like a thermally activated
process. So i think it's probably exponential.
And then they fit this nice exponential and
it fits the the cricket tripping beautifully.
And you can go even further because you see
if you got this far. Well now you see this
is a line. This is a line and we're going to do
that a lot when we go into reaction kinetics.
If you have a exponential and you take a log,
that's a line versus 1 over T. Right? That's a
line versus 1 over T. And so that's another way
you could look at data. They didn't do it there.
But, you know, you could plot for example--
you could plot 1 over T versus the log of
the number of vacancies. But the lattice-- the
number of vacancies is what we want. That ratio
is the concentration. That concentration
is in equilibrium at some temperature.
Okay. The lattice-- the number of lattice sites
is simply how many lattice sites you have,
in whatever volume you have, for whatever crystal
structure you have, for whatever element you have.
We'll see that in a few examples. So that's just
a concert-- it's the number of sites you have in
the chunk of material. And then instead of-- The
question this equation tells you the answer to,
is how many of those have a vacancy?
Because it's a thermally activated process.
And if you plot that log in Nv versus
temperature you get this really nice
linear line. And the slope of that
line is equal to minus E vacancy
divided by R or it could be kB. R.
Let's write this again per mole.
Or it could be kB if it's
per atom. You will see both.
You will see both. And this
intercept-- intercept--
is equal to the-- let's see-- the intercept
is equal-- what do i have here? The
log of n. Did i write it right? Log of n.
Okay. Alright.
Now, okay. Oh yeah. What else can you
do? Well before we go on to the defects,
this explains the doping. I kept calling
the doping in semiconductors a thermally
activated process. But look at what happens.
This is the carrier concentration in that
conduction band. The thing you've
been you've been learning about,
right? And thinking about. But look at it
now versus temperature. It's a straight line.
It's a straight line. This is-- this
is experimentally what you observe.
And the reason is because it's a thermally
activated process. And in fact, in this case,
what is the activation energy? Right? The
activation energy for getting an electron into
the conduction band is the gap. Right? And so now
you say germanium has a smaller gap than silicon,
which has a smaller gap than gallium arsenide.
The slopes are different. The slopes are different
because the energy that it takes in that activated
process is the gap. That's why the slopes are
different. Right? Okay. Alright. Now on to--
oh no i didn't-- I did want to mention this
because it's so cool. Where are these vacancies
going? Did you actually just take an atom from
the middle of a crystal and remove it? No.
Because that would cost way too much energy,
right? And so instead they have
to-- you call out to the surface.
It's a call out to the surface. Or,
you know, maybe the surface calls in.
It all has to happen on the surface. So what
ends up happening is a surface atom may go away
and then another one may take its place, right?
And then the next one, and then the next one,
and that's literally how you can rip
an atom out from somewhere inside.
But by the same-- that's literally pushing the
bookcase over. Right? And now you can push it
the other way and the surface atom could go
in to the crystal so that some atom inside is
able to fill a vacancy. It all comes to
the surface. This is a beautiful paper,
where they're showing how you get these rings.
This was published almost 20 years ago now. But
how-- they're studying how do vacancies actually
pull atoms from the surface specifically.
And what they did is they change the temperature
and they see islands growing and shrinking. Where
are those islands going and where are they coming
from? Vacancies. It's all about the vacancies,
right? And one of the things I loved about
this, is this is the abstract of this paper.
Look at this. Here we show the vacancy generation
and annihilation, right? Both ways on the 1-1-0
surface of an ordered nickel aluminum
inter-metallic alloy. Oh, I love reading
that because you guys all are experts in this
now. You know what that means. You know what that
means. Where do vacancies come from? Okay. And
now we got to make vacancies. Right? And so this
is the kind of problem you might get. How many
vacancies are in a centimeter cubed of copper?
How many vacancies are in a centimeter cubed
of copper? Well, now you know how to do it.
You're just going to apply this Arrhenius-like
behavior. You're going to apply this equation to
figure that out. And i won't go through
all the math but i do want to just
give you a sense of the types of questions
that you can now answer; that you know
how to think about vacancy formation.
So for example, in this one you've got
step one. Step one: you would find N.
Step one: you'd find N. How many sites do I
have? Because remember this equation is about
a concentration between the number of vacancies
and the number of available sites for vacancies.
And so step one-- well-- so step one you'd say N
equals Avogadro's number times 8.4 grams per mole.
Right? Divided by all this-- is such old-school
stuff right now, right? Grams per mole. Then you
look that up in the periodic table and it's 8
times 10 to the 22nd sites per centimeter cubed.
Why am I using centimeter cubed? Well because
that's what i was given the density in. So I'm
just leaving it in those units for now.
Right? And then step two you can find Nv.
So now we can apply our our equation.
Nv equals N, I won't repeat it, times
e. Now I've got my kB instead of R. So it's 9.9
electron volts divided by and then this is kBT.
Now I get-- so I'm given that it's a thousand--
wait a second. What's the term, oh a thousand
degrees. So do I put T equals a thousand. No!
No! You never use-- you only use Kelvin. 1273,
right? T is always in Kelvin
for any of these thermodynamic
equations. And I won't go through the math but
it goes something like 2.2 times 10 to the 19th
vacancies. I'll write the units here just for
completeness. Vacancies per centimeter cubed.
Now that seems like a lot but it's actually
not. You say it's like one in a thousand or
one in ten thousand atoms are missing and I'm at
a really high temperature. If I were at-- then
this is the power of what Arrhenius gave us.
If-- Because it's exponential. It's all about
probabilities and sampling and how many times
did i bump into that bookcase. If I'm down at
room temperature I've got so much less energy,
and so many more chances-- so many fewer chances
to deliver that energy. Right? Where the surface
is taking atoms in and out to create vacancies.
That at room temperature the number of vacancies
is 10 to the seventh instead of 10 to the 19th.
Right? So that's the power of that exponential.
That's the power of the exponential. You might
also be asked questions like this one. Right? So
--oh no like-- let me do this one. Then I'll talk
about your goodie bag. Where instead of now--
Okay. What-- Example two. What is the vacancy
formation energy in aluminum? And now notice,
instead of giving you the vacancy formation energy
per atom, I'm giving you other stuff. I'm
actually giving you how many vacancies you got,
at some temperature. Well that's-- This just going
in a different direction but it's using the same
math. So you can go in different ways, arrive at
the same kinds of equations, and get all of these
things, and I won't go through the details.
But in this case you get that Ea equals minus
kBT. I'm using kB because look at that...
the formation energy I'm asking is what is
the vacancy formation energy-- Okay, well actually
look at that. No, I just want to do it per atom.
It didn't say per atom but if I wanted to do a per
atom, I'd use kBT times log Nv over N. And so you
see 0.75 eV per atom. Now what's interesting,
copper was-- copper was 0.9, aluminum .75.
You're going to have a lot more vacancies
because it's exponential. This seems like-- 0.9,
.75 is kind of the same. No. It's going into an
exponential, so it has a really big difference
on how many vacancies you have at any given
temperature. Aluminum is going to have a lot
more because it's easier to get them in there.
Right? Notice I did the thing that I said other
people do and I don't really like. That's the
energy of the vacancy. The vacancy formation.
People call it activation
energy all over the place.
Okay. Now this is your goodie bag.
Now why am I giving to you? Because
first of all, this is the most sophisticated
vacancy generation machine you'll ever find.
There are exactly 500 beads in this. Exactly.
There are not 501. There are not 499. And you know
why? Because Laura has spent 7,000 hours counting
beads in every single one of these. So you have
exactly the right number. Then there's precision
tape and polycarbonate films maybe. And what you
guys can do is build your own crystal. It's a 2d
crystal. Here's what's so cool about this. Try to
get those vacancies out. Look at this! Dude-- None
of you can see what I'm talking about. [LAUGHTER]
There's a big vacancy there, I've literally
made this right in front of me. This is here.
And now I'm gonna say--
okay, I'll use temperature.
There's so many more. There's so many more because
I use temperature. This is temperature. You are
temperature. And you can run around, and you can
shake it, and all you bring it to the dance floor,
and on. Then you're like how can I get-- Whoa,
wait a second. I'll just quietly go down in
temperature and I'll get rid of them. Yeah,
tell that to your friends down the street. See
how long they go until they stop trying because
you guys know not to try because you'll never get
rid of them. You'll never get rid of them. You'll
always have vacancies and this is proof that you
will always have vacancies. You can try to tap it
like that. See if you can get rid of the defects.
You can't. Luckily that's a good thing because
defects are what make everything interesting.
Everything. This is your goodie bag. So you
can touch and feel-- Oh, but we got to cover
the other case. Because-- See I could have had
not just a metal, where every atom is the same,
but i could have had an ionic solid. You can
make point defects in ionic solids as well.
Right? So yeah. So if I had a defect in an ionic
solid-- well now you got to consider the charge.
I can't just keep pulling-- If this is sodium
chloride, I can't just keep pulling out
like one type of atom. If I take a sodium
atom out. Like imagine that's a plus,
minus, plus, minus. Right? The size-- if I take a
sodium atom out then it becomes charged. Because
remember the ionic bond is one of them, grabbed
it and it has it. And so if I take one out,
I've charged the crystal. You can't do that. It
won't let you. So if I take a sodium atom out,
a chlorine is going to come too. It's got to
come too. You got to keep it charged neutral,
if it starts charging neutral. So these
have special names because of that.
And there are two types of defects in ionic
point defects. We're still with point defects.
Local disruption in the regularity. One is called
the shocky defect, right? So in the shocky defect
you got both an anion and a cation are removed.
Cation. Now here's the thing- I should have put
's' because you may need to take
more than one out. Alright? Removed--
and because you got to ensure--
ensure charge neutrality. Charge neutrality. So
like you know-- If I had so inquiry that's fine.
But what if I had you know something else.
What if I had instead of sodium chloride.
What if I had like calcium chloride. So now what
if I had calcium chloride. Well that looks like
that. Because calcium goes to two plus. We
know this. Right? But chlorine is only minus
one so that ionic crystal is different. And
what it means is that if I remove-- if I remove
a calcium it's going to come out
as Ca2 plus but that means i need
to remove two Cl minus atoms.
That's the thing about shocking defects. You
got to keep the charge balanced. So now you--
It's not just a one for one. This could actually
be a way to take atoms out. Or if I want to take
chlorine out of this, we'll take some calcium out.
Chlorine will come out too. Right?
Could be a way to engineer it.
So that's a that's a shocking defect. But
the simpler thing that could have happened
is just that one of these atoms kind of moved
over. So now I didn't remove it from the crystal
but it just kind of wandered over into some site.
So like you know... here's BCC. I can have like
an atom-- so this doesn't look like an ionic solid
but suppose-- it doesn't matter. I could have an
atom leave a site and go-- Notice that there
are these voids, right? They're these spaces in
between other atoms. Well those spaces are places
where atoms can go. They're not-- It's not part
of the regular lattice but it's just-- it's like
a hole, right? Remember the packing fractions.
We never got above about three quarters. We
never got about three-- that means there's
still a bunch of volume in there that's free
volume. Right? Where is it? Well this kind of
defect will find it. Right? So you could have
the smaller ion migrate over, create a vacancy,
and it's going to find a place where it likes
to go. Ah. Okay. Yeah, we'll do this. And so--
so that's called a Frenkel defect.
So Frenkel defect is the other kind of special
name we give to a vacancy in an ionic solid, and
it's where one ion-- right-- anion
or cation. Anion or cation. Moves
to some open space. Open space in the lattice.
And you can already kind of feel where this
might be kind of common. It might be common in
situations where you've got a big size difference,
right? So like the silver halides are a
good example. Like silver chloride, silver
bromide, silver iodide. Those
are all good examples because
what happens there is this ionic structure has
a very big mismatch between the atom sizes.
And so you can see. Let's blow up a picture of
this is silver iodide, a cartoon. Look at that.
So those are the silver atoms and what you see
is because there's such a big difference in size,
you're going to have these pretty big voids.
And one of the atoms is small enough that it
actually doesn't mind-- it's actually pretty
easy to move it. Ah now, if you think about it.
Well if you have enough vacancies in there, then
maybe those ions can actually move really freely.
Because they're so small and the voids
are all kind of nearby. And you actually
can get a conductor, a good conductor, this
way. You're creating vacancies on purpose
so that one of the ions can move around. The
smaller one, right? That's what we do. We make
these solid-state ionic conductors. You need
the vacancies. You need the vacancies. Okay.
Now, I told you that we got this map here. We've
talked about literally just one. Luckily I don't
have nearly the same amount of material to talk
about these others. The vacancy is clearly the one
that I'm very interested in. The substi-- the
self-interstitial is actually pretty easy to
understand. The self-interstitial is actually
pretty easy to understand because it simply
doesn't really happen much. And the reason is, if
you look at this. Here's a picture of is basically
what i drew on the board, right? But now I've
put-- so these are-- this is not a vacancy,
right? This is a kind of point defect but it's
not a vacancy. I've actually added an atom into
the lattice and I've squeezed it in between all
the others. You can just feel how much energy,
how much strain, those other atoms are gonna
have to make and how much energy that's going
to cost. Those are high energy defect. So
a self-interstitial-- a self-interstitial--
self just means it's the same atom as the rest of
them, is very infrequent. Is very infrequent. The
self-interstitial-- let's see-- I'll just use this
one again. The self-interstitial has an energy of
formation of something like you know five electron
volts. And you think but-- five electron volts.
Self-interstitial. Self-interstitial.
It went in between, so it's not substitutional
it's interstitial and itself because it's the
same atom type. The energy energy of formation
is 5ev. I think 5ev doesn't even sound that much
higher than like the one ev you had for copper,
right? 0.9 ev. But it goes into the exponential,
right? So it's like one per centimeter cubed.
Literally. You get like one of these happening
per centimeter cubed instead of 10 to the 20th,
or 10 to the 10th, or you know many many orders
of magnitude higher. So the self-interstitial is
actually not very interesting. It's actually
not very interesting. Now because we have
like half a minute left, I'm not gonna
talk about these. We'll have a very brief
discussion about these last two types of
point defects and then we're gonna make
line defects on Wednesday. And my why this
matters, I'll give you on Wednesday for this.